and here is one of the greats of all
time a pro football hall of famer one of
the greats of all time at illinois
football as well one of the greats
of the chicago bears organization
joining me here on the rich eisen show
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line
courtesy of huddle up the let's talk
obesity campaign as part of getting
players who used to play in the nfl as
well as possible the great dick butkus
how are you dick i'm doing good how are
you doing i'm doing better for talking
to you uh there you go let's let's hop
right into this thing did you see the
game last night
yes i did see the game last night and uh
well i was a little bit more agitated
than usual watching the bears of late
i just don't understand what's going on
there you know what they ought to sue
that offensive line for attempted murder
they're going to get that quarterback of
ours killed
um
i think he's
he's our guy justin
and i think they got to do a a better
job of giving him some surrounding help
because like i say they're going to kill
that kid
so
when you watch them and you watch last
night
the throws that fields made towards the
end of the game that that that was a
that's that's it right i mean you you
know for sure he's your guy or you that
you figured that was the case before
this no you know i i just saw his
maturity over the just the past three or
four games than watching him he can make
the throws
uh
i'm certain about that it's just
they ought to have uh well i would say
that a little bit better play calling
and uh
and just help the kid out as best he can
with with play selections and so forth
but it's just
he's doing he's doing a great job uh
with
with
not much help up front so what what play
calls you want to see if you want to get
in there as well i'm doing some roll out
and stuff doing some uh patrick mahone
business after all maggie came from from
mandy reed's
school
uh
why is it a dive up the middle for two
yards with montgomery then another
dive for two more yards now you leave
the kid third and sixth or third and
seven plus
everybody knows in the stadium that
you're going to throw it okay so
devise some way a unique way of getting
him
and
movement rolling out or what have you
uh for the best chance of coming
completing a pass
because drop drop back pass and that i
just you know i hold my breath
well all right let me go to the third
rail subject do you think maggie's the
guy dick buck
uh
i i expected more let me say this i i i
expected more um you know people ask me
oh you think they're going to fire him
and mccaskeys will not fire anybody
during the year uh if anything happens
or pace i mean in chicago they're all
they're they're it's
you know they want to lynch them but um
i i i'm just disappointed in in
and everything the bears are doing i
mean i just i get so frustrated watching
them uh
i don't know that just
they got to start from ground zero but
they already have ground zero with
fields now let's get somebody around him
and in front of him to save his life
dick butkus here pro football hall of
famer here on the rich eisen show what'd
you think of what i mean the the
emphasis on taunting
jesus don't bring that up god
i mean i i mean it damned you know it it
it was you know you know that that's
that's the difference
of today's game versus you know
it errors before you know that that
that's that's bait i mean
if watching game films and you watch a
guy intercept the ball on his own
10-yard line let's say and he runs 90
yards and there's
not only the rest of the defensive team
running to the end zone you got guys
coming off the sidelines now right and
then they're doing their gyrations and
everything else and i know i guess the
director up there is directing the
camera on him let's show you know
oh i have fun does anybody go in the end
zone and do cartwheels when they miss a
tackle or drop a pass
please
please don't but that call on 59
yesterday last night uh that was
ridiculous yeah i mean he was just
staring at the bench you know
from
from
outside for like the middle of the field
he wasn't i think he was i don't think
he was inside the hashtag you know i
mean that wasn't and then when he came
off he bumps into the referee i thought
well maybe the guy the referee called it
on him for bumping him you know but said
he didn't by the way tony said he did he
was already pulling the flag as it
looked like the
he looked like and i'm going to talk
about this with the head of
the former head of nfl russ dean
blandino later on dick on this show it
did look like tony kind of like
moved his hip into the guy as he was
passing by it was weird the whole right
it really did and the guy just came up
for the practice class
[Music]
and then then when he runs off to the
sidelines they're chewing his ass out
then finally the coats came and it
looked like they apologized to him but
i would be hot too if that you know at
that stage of the game and then
being off sides
lining up offsides now
what
i you get frustrated here about this
this is it's ridiculous i'm sorry dick
but
isn't it that's what happened there
three times
you can't line up right
and it costs us a game
down here a second okay here we go let
me reset i'll do that i'll do the
professional thing together you gather
yourself dick butkus pro football hall
of famer here
on the on the rich eyes and [ __ ] because
it's about wellness dick this is about
wellness we need you well you know what
i mean we need you well how are you
feeling how's everything with you i'm
feeling terrific fantastic you know we
uh
uh
the nfl alumni are i have this uh
campaign with obesity and and they had
asked me to join forces because of my
foundation we we do
a thing called takes heart
where we give ebt
scans of people's heart
uh down there in orange county and so
there's a definite uh relationship
between obesity now and deaths and heart
disease and of course diabetes thrown in
and you know people are
you know it's over 40 i think nfl
retired players are obese
um
and everybody thinks well it's just diet
and exercise or whatever but there's a
lot of other factors that you got to
take into account as genetics and
harmonic changes and
you know lack of sleep stress
so what this is doing is trying to
address uh all these issues and
guys could go on online with uh nfl uh
alumni uh
obesity.org i believe it is
and you can sit there and talk it out
you know i i yeah you know another
reason is because 20 years ago
uh
i i did a scan uh for a favor for
somebody over there at saint joseph's
hospital in in orange county
and i come out and 24 hours later i had
a five-way bypass
and
i
when i came out of it in the recovery
room the doctor came up to me and
he was a chicago guy
and he said i said come on doc
what the hell was going on here i i felt
fine i might have been overweight a
little bit but i i generally i felt fine
and he says well dick the best way i
could explain it to you is that you had
one foot in the grave and one on a
banana peel because in 30 days it would
have been over for you wow
and i'm like whoa
and so i'm thinking now
with this obesity uh you know cancer and
heart disease were elevated because of
all the smoking
smoking has decreased heart disease has
decreased now it's skyrocketing again
and it's because of obesity
and
you know i think it's a selfish thing
that you're doing because i just think
back
if i would have taken care of myself or
or didn't go through the scan
i would never have seen my fine
grandchildren
so it's it's not an issue where it's all
about me it's
you know don't be selfish get yourself
healthy so you can live to see your
grandkids
and it's it's not that difficult to do
although
you know a lot of guys think it is
there's a lot of problems but again it's
it's not just diet and exercise
you know you gotta you know really work
at it and you know just i i just got
into it uh recently and you know i've
lost 40 pounds and i feel wow that's
amazing huddle up obesity.org
right for you and by the way you were
talking so passionately about fighting
obesity you i think you've been flagged
for taunting dick i think you've been
you're taunting obesity you're taunting
obesity
what's happening well
well isn't it like
everybody that's all about me
don't you think that's what's going on
with the dawning and everything
look at me
but when they blow a tackle or fumble or
throw an interception it's they're not
doing cartwheels as they walk off come
on oh man
dick mike is here
on the rich eisen show uh what was it
like uh suiting up against the lombardi
offense and uh back in the day
good one on that one liz lombardi on the
sideline you're a bear they're the
packers let's go what was that like dick
it was it was
a great time because those were probably
the best games as the team we played
because you know you knew they were good
and
you really wanted to show up but uh
i uh i just you know there was no
trickery involved they just were so well
uh owned that execution that
you know the sweep and all that stuff
everybody knew it was coming but it's
just their guys did a great job of
preventing you from making tackles and
i really enjoyed playing there because
to me at that time as a rookie even
going to
green bay it's you know title town this
is it man you know because i used to
watch ray nitsky uh because i met him as
a sophomore when i was at illinois or
when i was in high school going to go to
illinois
and so i always followed him and i still
remember when he was on what's my line
after they beat the
the giants or somebody and he came on
with his glasses and bald head and
they were asking him what he was doing
oh man he was he was in the uh oh was he
in the middle of like commercials too
let's see
uh i don't know if he he was okay
because well the guy who always used to
come through the miller light
commercials at the end was madden
bursting through right and then we've
got a photograph of those old days of
the miller like commercials like i mean
the the the people on the screen
i mean there's madden rodney dangerfield
boog powell you're leaning on boog
holding a miller light with bubba right
next to you and you're leaning on billy
martin who's sitting next to mickey
spelaine give me a story
roll roll roll one out for me here dick
what was it like so we're
so every christmas
we would do
you know everybody would do their little
individual uh
commercials during the year but at
around christmas for christmas we would
do a uh
commercial with everybody 60 second one
so we were all in this board room
sitting and so each guy had their lines
and everything else and so we would
deacon jones would always jag rodney
dangerfield because he you know we were
all the peons and we had to be there and
sit there for the whole duration of
setup and everything
rodney would walk in when he was
to say his line
so uh
uh i think it was boom boom jeffrey on
uh he says you know rodney's like saying
something you know to the director and
so boom boom jeffrian says come on
rodney stage lines
and then
without hesitation rodney says hey boom
boom how's your sister bang bang
[Laughter]
and you know
i'm sitting there like this guy must
have lines
ready to go for everybody because we
gave him such a hard time because
so
there was a makeup guy putting powder on
on deacon and
he looked like
look at him he slapped
the
rise
than the commercials actually and i
think it's probably one of the biggest
mistake
miller light has made by getting they
would can you imagine they would have
had material forever forever of course
exactly that's the stuff from behind i
mean my favorite one is being a new
yorker was george steinbrenner and billy
you know after he rehired billy for like
the umpteenth time and they argued about
taste great less filling and he fired
him again i mean that's just
that's one of the best commercials of
all time yeah unbelievable
oh man
that was and then of course i got i just
you know by by the way dick you got to
come into the studio because i have so
many questions for you about your tv
career
you were in every television show in the
1970s
i mean
yep
are you aware i mean like what what do
you get what do you get checks for
residuals do you get like residual
checks for for uh rich man poor man
still or you do you get a rockford files
residual check still yeah you know what
the ones that you do early yeah
i mean
uh
it
they it changes like i don't know if you
get a hundred percent uh residual that
goes to 90 80 you know every time so i
get some for nine cents
three cents in europe
so uh believe me i'm not i mean i wish i
would have been on a series like
uh anybody that's been in that for a
number of years they they're really
raking it in
27 episodes of my two dads dick i wrote
that one down on my uh six million
dollar man matlock no you were uh you're
the famed tank mason on murder she wrote
in that one episode i almost had a
series uh spin off from macgyver come on
yeah i had uh they had me up there twice
oh
yeah there you are you're we got a
picture of you with uh richard dean
anderson you're holding some sort of
plastic bag yeah you know you're making
stuff with macgyver that's a big deal
yeah back in the day oh my gosh yeah so
fooling them all
[Laughter]
big time man big time all right dick so
again everyone go to
huddleupobesity.org to learn more about
getting well and check things out for
you the butkus foundation you've got
that i play clean program encouraging
teens to stay away from
from uh peds
and then the buckets award when do we
find out who's the winner this year uh
we'll find out around uh december
uh the week first week of december
december 7th to the 10th or so right uh
yeah you know what what we do
differently is that we don't have a
rubber chicken banquet and tuxedos and
have guys come fly out during finals
uh would go to their particular school
okay so that their coaches family and
friends can enjoy it uh the success that
the kid has so okay yeah and then we're
gonna have uh our first awards show uh
in february they're at aqua caliente and
uh palm springs so okay we'll bring in
all the winners there i hope well when
you're on the way there from the beach
stop by here and you can come in and you
know really speak your mind on things
dick when you're coming okay you know
that's what people tell me i should say
what i think
i just don't i don't want to get myself
in trouble
okay you've succeeded not to do that
here dick don't worry
and that's
take care of yourself dick bud cause
you're the best that's dick butkus right
here on the rich eyes and show everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here